[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
consacré à la question de la jeunesse
dans les villes qui sont les jeunes
quelles sont leurs attentes comment on
peut y répondre on va en parler avec
trois jeunes et élus derrière
audrey le père bonjour enchanté mersque
l'invitation mais non cette vers sid est
redevenu et on va parler de la jeunesse
vous venez d'organiser délire à poissy
puisque vous êtes conseillère municipale
de poissy une grande fête de la jeunesse
qui a eu lieu le 4 juin on en reparlera
vous nous direz pourquoi vous avez fait
cette fête mais aussi pourquoi qu'est ce
que c'est une politique de deux là
dedans la ville poe pour les jeunes et
parfois avec des quartiers différents
impossible il ya des quartiers
différents
julie léonard bonjour bonjour santé
orientez vous êtes à doite deuxième
adjointe au maire d'orgeval
et vous êtes en charge des affaires
scolaires des sports de l'état civil et
du développement j'ai tout dis
qu'il ya les scolaires il ya aussi la
jeunesse évidemment évidemment et puis
le scolaire le pass vert c'est le
démarrage avant oui parce que la demande
a décollé à quel âge commencer le jeûne
un jour
c'est une grande question silberman cas
bonjour bonjour c'est pour la mutation
enchanté et elles seront chantées aussi
vous êtes adjoint au maire de oui et
vous êtes délégué à la jeunesse et aux
nouvelles communications et ça c'est
intéressant parce que c'est une
appellation nouvelle mais intéressant
tout nous dire et peut être en quoi ça
consiste les nouvelles communications
ces écoles des réseaux sociaux c'est en
fait pour tout vous dire
j'ai commencé qu'on est élu en 2020 j'ai
commencé avec ses deux étiquettes
jeunesse et nous venons communication
ensuite on a avancé légèrement dans le
mandat et j'ai arrêté avec l'étiquette
commune ou la décoration et je suis
maintenant maire-adjoint la politique de
la ville va se montrait bien un quartier
en prioritaire de la ville actuellement
mais on a un quartier en v l'anc le
maire a décidé de me donner une nouvelle
étiquette donc je suis toujours un peu
la communication mais un peu moins un
peu moins mais toujours la politique de
la ville c'est aussi c'est très très
important proposé pour les jeunes c'est
ça même si vous n'êtes pas
spécifiquement dans ce qu'on appelle les
quartiers de la politique de la ville
c'est ça mais je pourrais vous parler de
deux nouvelles communications
absorber ces nouvelles communications
j'ai posé est intéressant parce que ça
peut être aussi des réseaux sociaux une
importance fondamentale
on le voit dans avec des choses
positives avec des choses qui sont plus
négatifs comme le harcèlement scolaire
etc ça peut ça peut exister donc on va
parler de tout ça et mais on va
peut-être commencer par très derrière
par un peu de vous de vous présenter
vous dire pourquoi vous êtes engagé ben
voilà on s'engage pour quoi faire c'est
la première partie de cette émission
[Musique]
à londres et on va commencer avec vous
si vous voulez bien
donc vous avez été élu quand pour la
première fois donc c'est mon premier
mandat lors du sommet g20 j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir cette rencontre avec karl
olive et les marges sont ici mon
engagement vient de très loin bien
évidemment de par ma famille mes
grands-parents de pâte est immense dans
une famille de deux personnes qui sont
alors oui
logique donc on peut uniquement du côté
de mon père et puis aussi au niveau
d'éducation ma mère qui a été pendant 40
ans conseillère principale d'éducation
dans des lycées professionnels
donc les sujets complexes j'ai grandi
avec ça j'ai toujours été animé par ce
type de sujet est encore plus parce que
voilà j'ai aussi une carrière dans la
communication visuelle j'ai fait mon
mémoire sur l'adolescence donc c'est des
choses qui sont effectivement inné et
donc sa part de très très loin et c'est
vrai que au fur et à mesure de ma vie
personnelle professionnelle
et puis la politique j'ai fait
énormément de belles rencontres
évidemment les quarts ludique quand il
m'a proposé cette délégation s'était
totalement
je saurai c'était tellement évident mais
je me suis dit
mais puis achevé totalement passionnée
et c'est vrai que voilà c'est une espèce
de représentation mais c'est aussi des
sujets donc c'est important de pouvoir
un peu fédérer voilà j'ai toujours une
citation que que je partage toujours de
andré malraux qui dit bah la jeunesse
c'est un peu comme une religion on finit
toujours par se convertir et donc ça
fait partie aussi mon engagement dont il
ya énormément de sujets que je connais
que j'aimerais style fédérer donc c'est
aussi un peu cette impulsion que qu'on
souhaite aussi partager donc il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'engagement des
cuillères de vie très longtemps
après aussi de ce que voilà des espoirs
de ce nouveau politique mais c'était
intéressant de savoir voilà quelles
étaient les motivations de votre
engagement
julie léonard
je suis une jeune élue j'étais nue en
2020 mais on va le dire tout de suite je
vous ai tous les trois élus puisque
c'est le faible appétit ou la visite
tout à l'heure donc vous êtes tous les
trois dans votre premier mandat
exactement et
et donc je suis arrivé à ar je vais donc
la ville où je suis élue en 2015 à ce
moment là je suis devenue maman aussi
pour la première fois 12 2010 pas la
sociabilité j'ai habité versailles puis
dans d'autres villes mais je suis arrivé
à orgeval et en arrivant en devenant
maman j'ai voulu m'investir davantage
dans la vie de mon enfant donc je suis
devenu
parent d'élève donc dans une association
pour m'investir dans la vie scolaire de
mes enfants avant ça j'ai été directrice
d'une grande enseigne de sport donc
j'étais toujours impliqué dans la partie
sportive et de l'importance du sport
dans la vie des enfants et surtout des
adolescents
et maintenant je suis aussi enseignante
donc en tant qu'enseignante dans un
lycée avec des études des élèves de
cette tranche d'âge je vois bien aussi
les enjeux qui peut y avoir pour
accompagner des enfants et puis parfois
les limites de l'éducation nationale sur
certains aspects et qui a besoin du
relais local d'une ville pour
pour les aider donc le fait de m'engager
j'ai rencontré hervé charles haley le
maire d'orgeval pendant la période
électorale j'avais pas du tout
d'environnement politique j'avais pas du
tout cette ambition ça ne me demande pas
forcément mais en étant parents d'élèves
est engagée dans les problèmes
quotidiens je me suis très vite rendu
compte que si on avait envie d'aller
plus loin d'en faire avancer la ville
dorval qui se rajeunit énormément et qui
a besoin de nouvelles infrastructures de
vos nouveaux modèles d'organisation
nouveaux événements eh bien il fallait
s'engager et que 6 des jeunes ne
s'engageait pas bien on avait toujours
pouvoir pointer du doigt ce que ne font
pas bien leur ai dit de faux faux faux
il faut s'engager donc c'est c'est pour
cette raison là c'est intéressant parce
que généralement contours depuis un
moment généralement on se replie sur sa
famille et là vous que lui laisse vous
êtes maman vous êtes élu vous êtes
enseignante vous avez comment vous
arrivez à
avoir un emploi du temps qu'on va
menacer
en ce moment me demande ça prend combien
de temps tu as ta vie d'élu c'est pas
tellement le temps qui est prenant enfin
qui est le plus prenant dans la vie
d'élu c'est la charge mentale on parle
beaucoup en ce moment d'ailleurs de la
charge mentale notamment des femmes et
des mamans et la charge mentale d'un
début elle est très très chargé parce
que quand on est élu les problèmes des
habitants c'est le jour et la nuit c'est
des week-ends c'est la semaine c'est le
souhait pas d'horaires et quand vous
vous baladez même dans la forêt avec
votre chien vous croisez des voisins et
on va vous parler des problèmes de
poubelles d'urbanisme et c'est donc
votre vie début c'est tout le temps donc
c'est plus la charge mentale qui en
effet prenantes et vous dites jamais
quand l'europe qu'est ce que j'ai très
souvent très souvent très souvent je me
dis mais qu'est ce qui m'a pris qu est
ce que vous connaissez c'est pourquoi
chaque fois je me donne en fait je le
fais aussi pour mes enfants récit oui
ces deux engagements presque personnelle
lien c'est un engagement de radiall et
mignonne et qui deux cubes equidia
collectif fabriquer les infos sont
engagés aussi parce que ils ont vécu la
campagne électorale ils savent ils
découvrent c'est que la vie locale et
finalement c'est aussi motivant de
montrer l'exemple à ses enfants
longtemps que les choses se font pas
tout seul que c'est aussi parce qu'on
s'engage et qu' il ait eu s'engage aussi
qu'on a tous notre part de
responsabilité dans ce qui se passe d'un
point de vue local donc c'est un gars
bien lotis mais c'est bien sylvère
mon engagement et vient de loin géré
depuis
depuis toujours donc depuis depuis le cp
franchement j'ai toujours été déléguée
de classe ah oui j'ai perdu
j'ai perdu qu'une élection j'aime
souvent répété en cp
j'ai toujours gagné jusqu'à 10,6 hier
que vous avez appris comment gagner une
élection en place dès 7
ans 8 mois
j'ai souvent j'ai fait du sport au
niveau donc sans permis de carbone du
foot voilà du foot j'ai fait les
championnats de france 16 ans 18 ans est
donc dédié aux et des quatorze ans j'ai
fait mon rouge rouge et c'est le racing
club de france car ensuite
boulogne-billancourt maison comme des
gros clubs de la région parisienne
donc j'ai j'ai souvent regardé comment
ça se passait à côté 1 et file à côté du
benchmark et j'ai toujours voulu
apporter apporté dans ma ville mon
engagement n'a commencé vraiment en 2015
j'ai fait pas mal de tournois
intervilles où je coache les jeunes les
jeunes du quartier dont je suis issue et
à partir de ce moment là j'ai dit à mes
amis qu'il faudrait créer une
association pour pouvoir créer un
mouvement pour les jeunes pour
accompagner ou appuyer ce que la
municipalité faisait et fois il pouvait
avoir quelques manquements donc ça a
commencé comme ça on a créé une
association
n'at on avait quatre pôles un pôle
sportif donc avec tous nos événements
notamment sur plus ou moins sur le foot
ensuite on fait du culturel m'a fait du
social on a fait tout ce qui est du cas
sion donc à présent de ce moment là on
s'est fait connaître connaître dans la
ville et on est dans la décider d'un peu
plus engagé d'accord pas partir de ces
apporteurs de vraiment de 2017 où j'ai
rencontré - le maire julien chambon la
règle de la ville de houilles est donc
en 2017 on a vu qu'on avait un peu les
mêmes idées et la même vision pour la
ville de demain parce que quand on fait
de la politique on fait de la politique
pour nos petits enfants c'est comme ça
que je vois les choses donc nous on est
une ville qui se transforment pas mal
avec le r e qui va arriver en alu ra
c'est une vie d'une strate a peut-être
33 mille habitants mais on n'a pas dit
ça c'est important de eur
33 mille habitants brouille orgeval
cette ville
voici les habitants sur une superficie
de 13 5 tu m'as carré donc c'est vrai
que je me concentre à bien une
concentration et non avec 14 quartiers
trois quarts des plus grandes villes
par des latéraux pu mais c'était bien de
préciser parce que on verra tout à
l'heure que évidemment les problèmes qui
se posent sont pas forcément partout les
mêmes donc l'engagement pour la chesnaie
ce moment il était vraiment primordial
parce que je pense qu'il fallait
apporter un nouveau souffle
un nouveau souffle et dans la ville avec
de nouvelles idées avec les nouvelles
communications notamment qui évoluent
les moeurs des jeunes ce sont plus les
mêmes qui qui a 10 ans donc bon moi j'ai
eu la chance d'être d'être vue là depuis
toujours donc j'ai fait les différences
entre j'ai vu un peu l'évolution par
rapport à ce qu'ils faisaient dans la
jeunesse et j'étais un peu nostalgique
aussi d'un sérieux d'une certaine époque
où ai je voulais apporter à porter ça
donc c'est pour ça que je me suis engagé
sur une une campagne ensuite maintenant
voilà on poste et j'essaie d'apporter de
votre
niveau et vos actions
justement vous êtes tous les trois très
très engagé on le voit dans cette
politique de la jeunesse est ce que est
ce que c'est partager je lui dis pas non
pas de dire du mal des autres inversée
est-ce que c'est partagé par tous les
élus est ce que on vous regarde
on regarde parfois un peu comme d'aider
des gens qui s'occupent d'une chose
qu'on connaît pas ou tout le monde cette
conscience que c'est très important
c'est de la politique de la jeunesse
alors moi je suis déjà très content de
pouvoir représenter les couleurs de
poids si effectivement on arrive sur un
nouveau mandat on a les anciens élus
qu'effectivement ou une très très bon un
très bon mandat en fait et donc
effectivement il faut travailler en
bonne intelligence on a effectivement
des sujets qu'il faut effectivement
partagé avec différents différents
collègues que ce soit sur la mobilité
que ce soit sur l'environnement soit son
numérique est un secteur très très très
important pour pour les jeunes alors
évidemment quand on est nouvelle dans un
mandat on se demande c'est qu'il doit
elle vient et effectivement il ya ses
preuves à faire après ce qui est
important c'est pouvoir acquittement
fédérer une confiance travailler en
bonne intelligence et avancer dans
l'action parce que c'est ce qu'on attend
final c'est au plus tard aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que c'est trouver des
solutions avec différents partenaires
travaillent effectivement mon
intelligence avec les services de la
ville les administrés les écouter au
maximum aussi d'être sur le terrain moi
c'est vrai qu'au quotidien il ya la
source nous quel guichet unique de la
jeunesse avec qui on échange et qui ont
réfléchi et puis on se projette c'est
très important pour les jeunes après la
causerie de pouvoir me dire qu'est ce
qu'on fait demain et comment ce projet
est effectivement sur sept mais
l'impulsion 7,7 jeunesse mais c'est
aussi ce qu'on se doit apporter en tant
que nouveau venu il ya des sujets et
c'est vrai qu'il ya du travail et un peu
oublié la côte est ce que mon nom c'est
une avancée on veut aller encore plus
loin et justement est ce que parce que
parfois c'est comme ça quand on
contourne aborde quand on arrive en
politique en arrivant aux
responsabilités comme comme vous avant
dérive on se dit voilà il faudrait faire
ça c'est facile c'est assez simple est
ce que quand on est confronté à la
réalité de la décision politique il n'y
a pas un peu de frustration d'ailleurs
parfois en se disant ah ouais mais ça
n'avance pas aussi vite qu'on voudrait
parce que ben voilà il ya des étapes à
respecter
si je peux prendre la parole
c'est vrai que la frustration est un
grand mot politique parce que le temps
politique est un tweet dans la part
c'est vraiment un temps long pour mettre
un projet ça peut prendre pas mal de
temps des fois on voit des projets
bloqués après qui font ressurgir six
sept mois après mais comme la politique
et est un temps long il faut prendre son
mal en patience et surtout essayer de
toujours avancer de comprendre les
différentes personnes autour du projet
parce que à une administration
qui bossent et des fois c'est pas
évident ils ont plusieurs sujets
suivants suivant l'effectif donc à steve
wallace et il faut se dire que la
politique interne l'essentiel c'est
d'arriver au bout du projet vous
disposez avec derrière l'axé avec avec
l'appui évidemment des autres élus et
des maires il ya ce fait qui compense un
peu en vain c'est vrai que c'est ce que
disent les mères c'est pour ça que c'est
un mandat qu'ils aiment beaucoup aidé
les d'ailleurs idées qui sont les élus
préférés des français c'est qu'on voit
quand même assez vite et résultat de ce
qu'on fait c'est pas comme si vous êtes
ministre
je sais pas si vous analysez la santé
claude zidi forme plus de médecins il
faut quinze ans pour faire des médecins
bon que ça c'est plus là c'est vrai
qu'on voit aussi des vous avez fait
cette fête de la jeunesse
samedi 4 juin
voilà ce que vous avez vous l'avez voulu
vous l'avez organisé et vous avez vu le
résultat deux mille 2000 à être sur la
place de la république évidemment les
administrés ne voit que les résultats
les actions qu est ce qui a été fait
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une ou les
journées portes ouvertes à la source il
ya eu effectivement la jeunesse en fait
on a en un guichet unique avec les teams
en de nombreux dispositifs donc au final
c'est on va faire le la liste de ce qui
a existé de ce que je rejoins totalement
silvert sur le maître mot c'est la
patience c'est effectivement être
pragmatique c'est trouver des solutions
et au sein de de poissy il ya de
nombreux dispositifs qui sont malades
sont là la source qui assemble delà de
la place de république on a le bij
mobile on a des bureaux d'information
genèse qui vont se déplacer dans les
différents collèges les lycées dream on
a effectivement un lieu un coup de jeune
en fait sur la psychologie sur la santé
on a des activités qui sont introduits
mes nouvelles on fait beaucoup beaucoup
de propositions donc c'est vrai que je
rejoins silvert sur le fait de pouvoir
travailler aussi avec les équipes de la
jeunesse mettre en corrélation avec les
services de la mairie et se fait en
deux temps en temps effectivement faut
refaire le point moi j'ai change
beaucoup c'est que les mamans de est
différente des différents quartiers les
informer sur ce qui existe aussi sur les
activités sur les mains
main oui parce que les mamans sont
victimes les premières être inquiètes
sur sur leurs enfants pour le terrain
voilà julie elle à la tromperie c'est
vrai que le fait pour échanger avec les
mamans gravitent karting on a des
réunions régulièrement 2h 3h c'est comme
le disait jules grare et c'est vrai que
le rôle des femmes dans les quartiers il
essentiel et crucial et ben on en voit a
besoin de plus d'aidé par an sur les
quartiers un peu pris prix hôtel parce
qu'il devient un peu plus aussi il ya
des parents liés à des cartes people
était impossible voilà il ya trois et on
a aussi beaucoup de familles
monoparentales
soit c'est le père c'est la mer
effectivement la maman est la première
concernée sur l'éducation sur qu'est ce
qui se passe au sein de ma ville qu'est
ce que je peux faire et c'est pas de
désert un communiqué les informer sur ce
qui existe c'est vraiment à 5 10 minutes
de chez elle mais vraiment c'est du
terrain du terrain parce que il ya
énormément de choses qui existent
sur la ville de poissy encore une fois
il le fait de pouvoir après la cosi de
dire écoutez voilà on échange il ya des
moyens par exemple on a des vacances à
20 euros on a des choses très sur la
culture aussi c'est pareil très
accessible qu on a tout ce qu'il faut
maintenant aujourd'hui c'est ok la copie
dépasser qu'est-ce qu'on peut raconter
qu est-ce qu on peut que tu me partager
fédérer voile avec six verres on a des
projets aussi en commun sur la dictée
mais tout ça se fait effectivement du
temps mais les administrés eux ce qu'ils
regardent c'est qu'est ce que c'est que
voilà la gêner son café thé faudra
justement trois ans c'est important je
parle des relations vous pouvez avoir
avec les autres élus
les relations avec la population et avec
les jeunes est ce qu est ce qui est une
relation directe avec déjà 12 10e c'est
important les maires non mais par
exemple mais est ce que parce que vous
aussi être regardés entre guillemets
comme des notables enfin comme un est ce
que veut dire il est y est donné avec
eux vous êtes maintenant vous êtes l'élu
le responsable non oui enfin bon tout ça
ça change un peu alors alors je vais là
on a une problème ce qui est un peu
différente nous on est de ville qui
grandit énormément qui sera
généreusement passer votre cadeau
pour les anciens élus on vous parlait
des anciens élus et du regard les jeunes
ce n'est pas qu'ils ne les considère pas
ils ont conscience de son jugement là et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on fait
équipe pour autant
la difficulté c'est de ne plus en avoir
peur parce que pour certains anciens les
jeunes aigles des jeunes perturbe un peu
quoi
de l'argent à une mairie passe quand on
finance les activités le périscolaire
les événements donc le jeune coûte de
l'argent et le perturbe
donc il faut qu'elle
m'avait surpris et une des raisons
majeures jeux valve honnêtement c'était
une ville plutôt que doit
traditionnellement un plus tout plutôt
bourgeois les calmes et
une défaite il avait surpris en arriver
à un jeu mais c'est qu' il n'y avait pas
de bains ou très peu de banc et et en
tant que maman sortie d'école prendre le
goûter c'est sur un banc avec d'autres
vraiment c'est plutôt sympathique quand
on a une aussi jolie ville fleurie avec
des beaux-arts mais tu sais et je le
soumets une des premières réunions on a
parlé de ça avec les hôteliers mais
pourquoi on prendre mais très bas des
pentes aussi simple que ça puisse l'être
d'installer quelques bancs c'est
intergénérationnel ça sert à tout le
monde c'est le bien public
avec les gens parce qu'on s'assoit sur
un banc on rencontre du monde armé le
banc fait du bruit de bons fait du bruit
parce que ce soit gens vont s'asseoir
donc les jeunes vont s'installer etc etc
donc la peur des jeunes c'est ça il a
fallu d'abord découdre un peu c kon nom
des jeunes ce ne sont pas que des abdos
sûr qu'ils font des rodéos dans les
villes c'est aussi des jeunes qui
s'investissent qui a envie qui ne le
montrent pas forcément mais qui ont
envie et de mon métier de prof je me
rends compte de cet enjeu relationnel en
donnant de l'intérêt en portant de
l'intérêt aux jeunes les emporte en
retour et il faut à un moment qu'il y en
ait un qui commence eelv aux gi joe de
considérer les élus nos trois ans et ça
c'est tout d'abord qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour créer ce lien donc cette marque de
respect de les responsabiliser de leur
faire confiance après une confiance se
perd mais par contre il faut commencer
par la donner et c'est tout l'enjeu de
la de nous de notre mandat c'est via des
infrastructures via une salle
intergénérationnelle qu'on est en train
de créer les mobiliser sur des
événements créés nous on n'a pas de
conseil municipal des jeunes donc ça
c'est notre première étape pour la
rentrée on veut avoir un conseil des
jeunes allogènes à huy et mais je veux
pas m'en faire un juste pour en faire un
j'en veux un avec un budget une mission
et qui s'engagent cliquez alors qu'ils
aient du concret quand général des
jeunes s'est excusé quel âge alors nous
on a décidé de cibler la difficulté
c'est des cons à orgeval c'est de capter
nos collégiens aux lycéens qui sont
d'une population comme dans beaucoup de
villes qui sont difficiles à capter
parce qu'ils sont pris par you lie ce
nom on a mis un collège difficile de
pourvoir et nous achever les jeunes vont
au collège public de chambourcy puis au
lycée de du corbusier à poissy sont de
très bons établissements mais ils vont
aussi une grand en grande partie dans
pleins d'écoles privées sur saint
germain où exactement et donc on perd ce
lien avec eux assez vite donc notre
conseil municipal des jeunes ce sera
essentiellement des cm2 pour un mandat
de deux ans et puis des collégiens
lycéens qui veulent s'y investir seront
les bienvenus mais on va essayer de
capter l'âme on arrive où on est très
bon c'est à l'élémentaire parce que là
c'est chez nous c'est dans notre ville
on a toute une équipe sportive on à la
ville de laval a engagé des dés matters
qui ont des brevets d'encadrants sportif
qui anime les heures de sport dans
l'école élémentaire et pour les grandes
sections de maternelle donc tous des nos
élèves qui sont hors jeu valve ont des
heures encadrés par des encadrants
sportifs
donc ça c'est aussi un moyen de créer du
lien il va faire découvrir le sport est
derrière de les capter
juste je reviens à la question que vous
vous posez aussi c'est le rapport
justement à l'apu blessure vous occuper
c'est à dire les jeunes comment ils vous
regardent es comment on en arrive
voilà obtenir leur confiance puisque
vous disiez c'est ça il faut les
considérer pour qui vous considèrent
mois pour
moi en tout cas
j'essaie de toujours proche de
toi parce que vous êtes élu vous êtes
passé dans un autre monde moi j'essaie
de rester proche après mois avant d'être
élu en 2020
2010-2020 j'étais encore coach avant que
la pandémie devienne arrêté j'étais déjà
avec des joueurs qui avaient plus de 19
ans donc lecture de rester proche donc
resté proche non ah oui on a la chance
d'avoir un énorme tissu associatif donc
c'est plus de dix mille licenciés avec
le sportif voilà 133 1000 habitants vous
rendez compte c'est vraiment énorme bas
dans les yvelines en est un la ville
mais à plus de licenciés au kilomètre
carré
si une ville
il fait vraiment bon vive et basse et on
va dire c'est culturel l'association
toujours
donc par exemple le club de foot le où
il ya sais je sais que c'est le
troisième club le plus de licenciés en
france donc c'est plus de mille trois
cents licenciés ensuite on a un deuxième
club de foot avec plus de 500 licenciés
le saut h donc il ya vraiment une de
cette culture landes donc à prendre avec
club de basket les clubs de hand aussi
qu'ils performent bien et donc c'est
d'essayer de toujours être proche et
nous en tant qu'élu faire des activités
et a toujours essayé de se déplacer et
venir n'a pas hésité pendant les
élections et dans vos est le même
et les gens le sentent quoi c'est ça en
tout cas j'ai j'essaye madrik là je
commence à me prendre et c'est de
toujours rester sur le terrain proche de
les écouter savoir à leurs besoins je
pense que c'est important essayer de
rester disponible
vous êtes fit
appel à l'alluré d'un sénateur de la
troisième république
barry bonds avant d'être élu on est
effectivement en contact des habitants
on est effectivement m'assois milieu
également ce parti mais toi aussi et
c'est partie du casting mais c'est vrai
sur le terrain on est effectivement sur
l'athlétisme le basket est effectivement
sur sur la source donc c'est vrai que
avant d'être élu c'est aussi pour ça que
le maire
respectivement les les gens nous
connaissent ou nous reconnaissent pour
bien vous répondre c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui voilà moi je vois
régulièrement la source qui est quelle
liste unique de la jeunesse il y avait
beaucoup de jeunes qui viennent c'est un
peu aussi en dire le curseur pour eux du
lieu où on se rencontre on fait des
activités on a trois trois maisons de
deux jeunes notamment à et andré malraux
il ya l'espace vanpoulle l'oncav d'élus
dans lequel les jeunes se retrouvent et
les rencontres et rencontrer les parents
et aussi d'avoir beaucoup de référents
qui sont contact au quotidien avec eux
donc à beaucoup de remontées sur andré
guillemet les problématiques ou les
solutions que je souhaiterais donc c'est
aussi un échange avec les références au
sahara et ses dialogues nous cultivons
par exemple à la fête de la jeunesse
les jeunes étaient très contents de les
rencontrer
envie de faire plein de choses et c'est
vrai que là c'est d'avoir un vrai
contact et ils les rencontres et les
rencontrer il doit participer un petit
peu alors développement parce que c'est
ce qu'ils attendent d'être accompagné
d'être encadré ces six à notre ni trop
longtemps qui luttent pour ainsi trouver
des fonds pour participer et faire
développer les différents sujets dans
les importants c'est alors ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que vous êtes
venu presque tout seul mais mais c'est
normal aux sports a parlé de sport et
non vivres non parce que au fond il ya
content des responsables comme ça de
notre politique pour la jeunesse il ya
un certain nombre de valeurs évidemment
qu'on veut transmettre et c'est vrai que
les valeurs du sport elles sont
formidables pour ça il ya des forts ya
l'un d'eux le travail il ya toutes ces
valeurs là c'est des valeurs voilà parce
que le travail sur les valeurs il est
important aussi des avis des déjà non
le travail sur les vagues le sport c'est
un des le sport est un vecteur de gueule
d'un trait unique et
universel que ce soit sociale culturelle
le sport c'est assez universel donc pour
les jeunes c'est un des bons moyens
aussi de les occuper un adolescent qui
est passionné par un sport et qui
pratiquent du sport c'est un adolescent
qui passe pas son temps à traîner qui va
faire attention à ce qu'il fait parce
que il est un pugilat
il va avoir un cercle d'amis qui va le
tirer vers le haut parce que c'est des
gens qui te solidarité il ya fait que ça
c'est important toujours et cette place
du sport elle est
primordial dans la vie d'un jeune sauf
qu'un jeune on en parlait tout à l'heure
ça commence quand un jeune on devient
pas le jeune comme ça ne devient plus
jeunes n'ont plus comme ça donc ça
démarre dès l'enfance est un enfant qui
a pratiqué du sport régulièrement à qui
on a transmis des valeurs fortes
régulièrement tout au long de son
parcours
ça devient un jeune qui est bien dans
ses baskets et qui va continuer dans sa
jeunesse certainement sûr il ya toujours
un peu de congé de la percée de la paix
de rencontres de choses extrêmes et mais
globalement un jeune une ville qui a
bien construit tout son parcours sur
l'enfance
créée a mis assez fort que ce soit par
le sport où il ya d'autres outils alors
je orgeval on démarre la grâce à des
enseignantes très motivés sur l'école
pasteur élémentaire avec nos classes de
ce1 tout un parcours d'ateliers avec
l'association sève savoir être et vivre
ensemble c'est frédéric lenoir qui a
valu à créer puis c'est bien et qui est
formulée que le droit qui est philosophe
est exactement ce sont des
chantres du bonheur
spotify est donc j'ai eu la chance de
voir son crime est d'avoir échangé sur
son dos film documentaire sur les petits
philosophes les valeurs qui font
travailler des enfants il soit la suite
vu ça avant de m'engager en tant que
élus et ce film m'a énormément ému dans
ce qui pouvait provoquer chez des jeunes
est venu ici mais en fait elle est
peut-être là aussi une partie de la
solution et puis en devenant et l'usmba
idée peut-être là aussi notre rôle c'est
de pouvoir financer ce type de projet en
tant que mérite si tenté que le projet
soit porté par des équipes pédagogiques
ce qui est le cas sur notre vie leurs
jeux valve est donc là on
dans la transmission de valeurs dans la
bienveillance dans l'écouté des autres
et dans l'ouverture
on est en plein dedans le le sport c'est
important il ya rien évidemment
2024 avec les jeux olympiques dans
lesquels bas les yvelines vont prendre
une part conséquente
et ça aussi pour les jeunes c'est une
motivation non
l'avis de poissy extrêmement sportive et
un tissu associatif qui est extrêmement
large part
saisi
ces poissons
de tourner puisque on a un maire carlo
ni qu'ils aient participé et encore plus
aujourd'hui lorsqu'il a été un
journaliste je suis fier des sports à
cames aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il a
fait le sport pas la nation donc où la
nation par le sport en fait c'est
pouvoir un clic et lille a fait un
rapport
sexuel à l'histoire de la jolie sur sur
voilà l'importance du sport ça a fédéré
nommément parce que ça pouvait aussi à
les différents jeunes qui n'avaient pas
forcément dedans vie d'orientation
notamment aussi faire le sport par la
prévention le score par les règles de
vie par l'éducation et c'est vrai que ça
a été un précurseur et c'est une ville
qui est extrêmement sportive on a du
basket on a du foot on a dû en on a de
la clé on a des triathlètes qui viennent
aux cadets et des références et sa porte
et c'est ça ou les gens on a besoin de
pouvoir les suivre donc les règles de
vie sur un terrain c'est effectivement
quand on est hors jeu voilà c'est qu'on
n'a pas suivi la règle donc c'est tout
une question de cadres et de règles de
vie il serait quand on parle des jo
voilà c'est pas demain c'est un peu
demain les oui
tout de suite moi même j'ai c'est que je
passe un style souvent avec le délégué
qui aux sports éric roger et on en parle
souvent su en victime en la dynamique ça
va porter sur la ville de poissy mais
parce qu'on à saint germain en laye qui
est juste à côté qui va accueillir les
prochains champions ils ont ouvert les
anglais exactement la latinva british et
donc c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
demain donc elle va falloir puis il va y
avoir le recrutement des bénévoles aussi
un pôle audio dans lequel les jeunes
évidemment pas joué un rôle prépondérant
à skis l'hiver on a la chance niveau de
la source de proposer des sources à des
sources heures à manger les mots à la
bouche mais des bourses à des bourses ce
cap en fait qui permet de donner un
certain budget aux jeunes qui veulent
développer leurs études et en
contrepartie de leurs de s'être
contrepartie ils donnent de leur temps
donc ils sont sur le terrain ils
viennent sont indiqués en événements
sportifs ou culturels et donc un espèce
de contrat gagnant gagnant donc avec
climent beaucoup de jeunes qui veulent
voilà à participer aux différents
événements sportifs et notamment pour
demain donc on est en train de mettre en
place ces structures là donc oui
on est on a eu le label label terre des
jeux donc nous les lieux au sport mais
cck y
travaille déjà sur sur 2024 avec les
différentes associations sportifs nous
paraît moi aussi je sais que des
commerçants font une activité
je pense que d'ici là d'ici deux
semaines
par projet ou 2024 donc ils vont
commencer à faire une rue piétonne avec
pas mal d'activités qui aura quiriau
donc c'est sûr que le sport on sait que
c'est vraiment cool demandé pour
l'hygiène de vie dans un premier temps
et un jeune qui fait du sport et qui
n'en fait pas un peu on peut aussi voir
la différence est là il dort la chance
dans vos villages
peut-être pas partout pareil aussi
d'avoir des infrastructures qui
permettent qui permettent de faire du
sport ce qu'elle ce qui est important
c'est très important et qui sont très
bien subventionné par la région les
locations et est ce qui nous aide à
renouveler notre parc sportif parce que
deux camps la population évolue mais il
faut revoir également les armes saisies
c'est quand vous doublez presque de
population c'est pas la même chose et il
ya un frein au dessus alors on va passer
maintenant peut-être va parler d'eux on
a parlé de vous de vos actions mais en
europe pour vieira sur quelques actions
que vous avez menées mais peut-être
qu'on va parler peut-être des des jeunes
quels sont les problèmes que rencontrent
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
jeudi deux verges je pense que vous
disiez tout à l'heure ni la jeunesse
mais vous avez raison il ya il ya
plusieurs jeux d'aces il ya des axes
différents à des problématiques
différentes
nous les problématiques sony en
filière technologique dans stm j'ai donc
des plus grands là oui j'ai deux
secondes jusqu'au terminal donc j'ai et
leurs problématiques
principales
métriques concept de quoi non leurs
pronostics principal c'est
essentiellement
ce tous pas sur des réseaux sociaux est
donc aujourd'hui décroché on voit en
tant qu'enseignant
les téléphones sont interdits en classe
mais on critique un mais à nous adultes
on n'est pas mieux on a toujours notre
les exemples pour les enfants et nos à
d'autres demain et donc les ados
d'aujourd'hui leur problématique elle
est essentiellement sur les réseaux
sociaux donc tout l'enjeu c'est de
proposer des activités des choses pour
sortir de cette dépendance des réseaux
sociaux et comment les capter les
réseaux sociaux sont aussi un bon moyen
de capter l'attention donc il faut qu'on
vive quand je l'évolué utilisées en même
temps au dernier vingt moderniser les
propositions aussi dans les villes on
nous parle on a essayé de mettre en
place une webradio donc avec avec des
jeunes des ados qui négocie des ados qui
participe donc ça permet de feu
d'apprendre à faire des montages vidéos
de réfléchir un peu plus loin non moi je
suis professeur de management et de
marketing et souvent mes élèves me dire
à moi je vais être community manager
c'est génial on est sur les réseaux
sociaux toute la journée alors oui oui
stratégie de réflexion de vous verrez et
toute cette partie là qu'il faut
travailler donc c'est l'occasion de leur
montrer un peu l'envers de ces réseaux
sociaux de leur expliquer un peu comment
ça fonctionne vraiment c'est comme un
footballeur
c'est bien des jundollah mais c'est du
boulot si c'est ça mais c'est vrai que
la question des réseaux sociaux est
importante yahia quand même je vais
revenir un peu à cette période qui était
quand même qu'il changeait beaucoup la
vie d'aider des jeunes des ados c'est la
période du coc vide quand même
peut-être qu'à faciliter et à accélérer
aussi le là
on est seul on et voilà
ça a marqué beaucoup les vous avez
l'impression que c'est de marquer
beaucoup y honnêtement c'est vrai que
déjà de la décence et un périmètre dans
lequel il ya beaucoup de paradoxes mais
encore plus avec l'aco vide on est dans
un isolement total et en même temps on
veut sortir on veut découvrir on veut
effectivement être à risque en cas de
l'essence est vrai que c'est un terrain
qu'elle ils ont envie d'aller au delà de
chez eux donc c'est vrai que les
paradoxes de visionnement était très
brutal on nage une hausse de 20% de
mal-être chez les jeunes en fait celui
ci les études qui montrent d'ailleurs
que c'est beaucoup plus fort c'est
laisser les jeunes que dans le reste de
la population qui a rêvé de ça il ya des
crises d'anxiété des crises de des
stations sont beaucoup plus fortes chez
les jeunes en décrochage scolaire je mal
être qui fait qu'on se construit
familiaux nous on a la chance d'avoir un
lieu écoute jeunes en fait dans lequel
il ya une psychologue puisque la qui
rencontre des jeunes vraiment
gratuitement et de manière anonyme et en
fait régulièrement voilà on en fait des
retours et c'est vrai que lors de la
copie d une augmentation de 20 % c'est
incroyable donc c'est vrai que tous ces
sujets là mais des des jeunes dans
quelle voie là ils sont ils sont chez
eux mais on est des ans les petits
appartements ils ont envie de sortir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait demain donc c'est
vrai que les vrais sujets ont parlé du
numérique tous ultime ans sur leur
téléphone mais qu'est ce qu'on dit
qu'est ce qu'on fait l'identité elle est
extrêmement majeur l'adn et le
développement si deux des adolescents
sont son climat mondial donc moi je
serais très très ravi de pouvoir
rencontrer des psychoses d'avoir un
échange ok on vit avec l'air du temps le
téléphone mais que ce qu'on en fait
comment est-ce qu'on peut effectivement
bien grandir en les accompagnant sur des
vrais sujets l'action enfin le
développement de soi même vous n'êtes
pas en été on a gagné parce que ce
serait je crois que l'on disait ben faut
arrêter quoi les téléphones et machin
très bas car ils sont encore est ce que
vous disiez sur le co vide les suivants
la danse des petits parfois des petits
logements j'ai eu aussi une inégalité
enfin face à cette crise ouais parce que
non mais je vous ne buvez pas de la même
manière si vous êtes en effet dans un
logement social
voilà à détroit dans une grande maison
un
hors jeu validé jeudi si je vois la plus
du côté avec ma casquette de prof c'est
on a noté avec les autres enseignants un
vrai changement dans nos classes depuis
le vide où on a toujours eu des cas
particuliers d'élèves dans des
situations compliquées maintenant on a
beaucoup plus mais c'est pas qu'elle
n'existait pas avant c'est que l'effet
confinement a fait comme une serre sur
ces les problèmes seulement de vie de
famille de situations de violence
parfois dans le coup dans
la parentalité qui ont fait exploser ces
problèmes et qui maintenant ressort très
fort dans les lycées dans les villes et
tout notre enjeu à nous c'est qu'est ce
qu'on propose pour accompagner est ce
que c'est des liens avec des
psychologues sur des thérapies douces
s'est défaite aussi cette chance de nous
hisser tellement c'était facho
ça y est on peut on peut tous se
rassembler et à être ensemble mais je
suis totalement d'accord c'est pour ça
que le fait de pouvoir fédérer se
retrouver la fête on attend que ça en
fait quand on est jeune on veut faire la
fête on va se retrouver entre nous et je
pense que c'est vraiment le coeur du
sujet on parle de problématiques mais
aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut c'est un petit
peu plus se retrouver oui voila moi j'ai
été en contact mais tout à fait samedi
j'ai échangé avec eux dit qu'est ce
qu'on fait à la semaine prochaine
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça reste alléchant
c'est vrai que voilà on continue à se
voir continue à célébrer à se rencontrer
en tête effectivement rencontré hors jeu
va rencontrer wii est développé en fait
ddd peut-être des actions encore plus
sur la la festivité un cas de la
prévention avec d'accompagnement et
peut-être voir des partenaires qui me
fait mouche sponsorisés aussi parce que
c'est important nous en tant qu'élu
cerner les serviteurs pouvoir tacite et
aussi ses projets actuellement c'est le
vert justement parlez de dysport tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que la période de
coville a été compliqué
la première question des jeunes quel
problème oui je pense que suivant les
territoires les problématiques sont
différentes d'agir donc c'est important
en tant qu'élu de le pouvoir au mieux
regarder la jeunesse parce que la
jeunesse c'est comme si il n'y a pas une
adepte des jeux de la jeunesse c'est
quoi c'est qui
donc c'est vrai que tu vas voir
différents différentes situations
suivant là où on habite des études qu'on
fait donc il est important
de pouvoir situer des gènes dans une
case pour pouvoir mieux les accompagner
cello disent qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes
droits et les mêmes problématiques tous
ont quand même besoin d'eux mêmes
problématiques et qui n'ont pas les
mêmes envies
donc ça déjà c'est un pro c'est
important de pouvoir mesurer toutes les
problématiques pour pouvoir y répondre
au mieux même si c'est vrai que c'est
parfois compliqué en tant qu'élus nous
pouvoir répondre sur tous les sujets
après c'est vrai que l'aco vide un
impact très important sur la vie de pas
mal de jeunes on l'a vu des jeunes en
souffrance
pour ceux qui habitent dans des
logements d'un logement sociaux c'est
complexe est-ce que ça alors ça c'est
vrai enfin vous avez tout à fait solide
est-ce que ça ça
marque evra est ce que ça continue
encore temps risque de cet épisode voit
là et je crois qu'il est plus profond
même mes fans ne s'est pas arrêtée avec
j'espère qu'à la fin c'est pas tout à
fait la fin de la commune s'est jamais
la fin mais
c'est déjà une ouverture c'est un
souhait des échanges quand on ira mieux
mais ça les a peut-être marqué aussi
psychologique bien sûr fortement quoi
laisser les a marqués passe d'être en
soit si c'est quand même trois ans dans
quelles poules de trois ans dans une vie
adolescente c'est extrêmement sa marque
extrêmement dans cette ère est là donc
c'est vrai que on a envie d'accélérer
encore plus vite se dit ok on va s'y
d'oubli l'aco vide on va faire la fête
en train d action et je pense que c'est
un peu là aussi quand on échange
estimant entre nous entre élus sur la
jeunesse on envie d'accélérer d'aller
encore plus loin et encore plus vite
parce que date de naissance enfin je
peux en parler il est enfermé - dessus
ses marques à vie en fait c'est là on se
développe c'est là on se sent saufs et
ont dit non à la société on
effectivement dans un développement
personnel et on voit là on se développe
en tant qu'adulte et on s'affirme donc
c'est un petit peu la nôtre en jeu aussi
en tant qu'élu sur la jeunesse de
pouvoir effectivement fédérer les
différents jeunes parce que on parle
justement des cubes et donc des
quartiers prioritaires de la ville qui
ont pas forcément des moyens et d'autres
jeunes qui ont peut-être plus de moyens
mais moi ce qui m'a également une équité
et cali aussi des politiques favorisées
puisque vous êtes à la politique de la
ville le savez personne mais c'est vrai
que dans ces quartiers de la politique
de la ville il ya aussi des ddd
initiative absolument formidable souvent
c'est ça ment pas seulement pas
aujourd'hui on a besoin effectivement
d'être initiés négative mais si tu dis
cative elle permet de c'est quand même
dingue et encore encore plus si on
encore nous on paye on a aussi envie
d'être encore plus accompagné aussi de
pouvoir effective mandat de soutenir
aussi
la jeunesse parce que c'est la jeunesse
dia n'est pas celle de demain la
jeunesse du numérique qu'est ce qu'on
dit qu'est-ce qu'on ne porte aussi de
pouvoir les accompagner et puis aussi je
pense avec les différents élus de
pouvoir effectivement développer des
nouveautés parce que c'est ce qu'ils
attendent et hier on veut pas en faire
quelque chose de nouveau et céder voix
faut inventer faut inventer et il faut
être en ont mais c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on revient avec son
des pauvres la page est blanche y en a
plus qu'à construire en seniors est-ce
que vous pouvez comme ça dans les
relations vous pouvez avoir justement
avec les avec les jeunes est-ce qu'on
peut on peut essayer de savoir quels
sont au fond là leurs espoirs leurs
craintes c'est vrai qu'on a on a dit
beaucoup et c'est malheureusement un peu
vrai jusqu'à enfin dans l'histoire
jusqu'à présent les les parents pensez
toujours que ça serait plus facile pour
leurs enfants on est dans une période où
aujourd'hui ça s'est retourné et on a
l'impression que c'est plus de 10 ce
sera peut-être plus difficile pour les
enfants que sanaa était pour pour pour
nous enfin pour vous en tout cas est ce
que est ce que c'est un peu pessimiste
de dire ça est ce que je pensais qu'il
ya l'espoir chez les jeunes on trouve
jamais perdre espoir ça c'est sûr après
je pense que on a la chance
déjà d'être yvelinois un département où
est il fait bon vivre quand même où il
ya de l'accompagnement que ce soit par
le sport ou pas de l'action sociale
après je pense qu'on a aussi en région
parisienne donc il faut juste aimer
vouloir et savoir où on veut aller et je
pense qu'après les ouvertures et les
ouvertures le travail c'est pas ce qui
manque
nombreuses
je vous sais qu'il faut pas voir cette
inquiétude est mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui mais ça l'a été salvail
et même beaucoup de dauphin de deux
chercheurs guinaudie sa fin et c'était
un sentiment quand même que ce serait si
l'inquiétude malgré tout pour les jeunes
parce que on n'arrête pas de leur
répéter que des allures c'est bon on
leur dit pas prendre ça veut dire mais
vous allez changer plusieurs fois de
métier dans votre vie oui et ça c'est
quelque chose que nous on n'a pas
forcément entendu quand nous on était à
leur place dans notre génération et on
leur dit
mam ou non mais c'est donc c'est très
récent donc été très engagé un nom
choisi c'est une formation eu des études
en se disant qu'on allait on s'engageait
pour la vie eux on leur dit attention le
parcours scolaire est tout aussi
engageant le par contre ce que vous
allez faire peut-être ne vous servira
pas parce que vous allez changer de
métier que je m'étais or
le métier que vous allez faire n'existe
pas encore aujourd'hui il arrivera
peut-être dans cinq ans donc donc ça
c'est très sanctionné pour des jeunes
parce qu'on leur dit il ya une farce
alors ces incertitudes jour pareil c'est
pas être anxiogène et en même temps ça
m'échappe est formidablement motivant
tout cela est rassurant
enfin vous de plein de facteurs mais ça
peut être aussi source d'anxiété pour
les jeunes ça c'est parfois difficile
c'est pour rejoindre c'est pour ça que
c'est important de pour les jeunes
d'avoir un accompagnement au sein de la
mensualité donc à la pression dans la
source nous on va voir le django je
pense que
ce sera un cheval aussi vous essayer de
nara des lieux d'accueil lui qui va
ouvrir en octobre la nouvelle salle en
centre-ville justement voilà enfin une
dynamique pour pour accompagner les
jeunes parce que c'est vrai que les
jeunes c'est vrai que avec les
numériques avec l'avancé
la mondialisation on sait pas comment ça
va être demain c'est vrai
deux sociologues notamment qu'ils disent
au fond
les jeunes sont de plus en plus tous
confrontés à des problèmes d'adultes et
c'est vrai que c'est 16 c'est vrai que
c'est oui par exemple mais menezes lui
il faudrait peut-être aussi retrouvé les
alpes et de l'insouciance de l'enfance
qui est qu une belle période aussi faste
vient on n'est pas toujours confrontés à
des problèmes graves quand on est jeune
et c'est vrai que donc c'est un des
problèmes peut-être qui se pose si elle
est jeune et d'une façon générale
qui aussi inculque aussi parce que c'est
eux qui sont les premiers en fait
concerner je pense que les jeunes
aujourd'hui les premiers d'angoissé
envie c'est d'aller effectivement qu'on
aime faire la fête mais ce qui est
important aussi c'est qu'on part du
numérique mais il faut absolument parler
de la mobilité on parle des quartiers
mais moi ce qui m'intéresse aussi c'est
pouvoir croiser les quartiers les faire
sortir de chez eux mais qu'ils acceptent
de la région du département aujourd'hui
elle de nombreux dispositifs qui
existent sur comment terminer les jeunes
en europe c'est à côté c'est à 3h 4h
donc c'est vrai que on parle
on est très passif avec son téléphone
c'est très bien mais ce qu'il faut c'est
de sortir de ça et aujourd'hui
maintenant on peut le faire il faut
effectivement les accompagner encore une
fois en tant qu'élu mais voilà on parle
de d'anxiété je pense qu'il faut aussi
parler de quelque chose de beaucoup plus
léger parce que parce que voilà on en à
l'europe aussi demain et je pense qu'il
ya encore des choses et les accompagnant
dans une position vite et c'est
important s'il leur arrivait et de
rassurer tous les jours les parents ta
dire voilà ce qui existe parce que pour
avoir échangé avec régulièrement voilà
ce qui existe parce qu'il est possible
de faire et des projets qui sont quand
même assez possible en termes de
financement la région aide aux
départements aide donc un monde et il
n'y a plus qu'à quelque part donc on les
prend par la main et c'est vrai que
c'est un accompagnement de terrain un
discours aussi et moi ce qui me pèse
aussi à chaque fois dans tous les
projets céda voiture de parité mais
aussi d'avoir tant de jeunes dans chaque
quartier qui puisse aussi entre eux se
reconnaître et se rencontrer à te dire
activement espace aussi dans tel
quartier good antenne rue ça m'intéresse
parce que je ne connais pas ça en fait
chez moi dans ma culture aussi le fait
de croiser en fait ces communautés parce
qu'elle est maman de communauté la
corrida renforcer les communautés et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que les forces du
ressort moi je le vois et c'est vrai que
pour quand j'étais jeune j'ai vécu aussi
à cergy-pontoise donc j'ai connu ces
communautés là j'ai connu aussi ça au
lycée le corbusier était étudiante donc
j'ai connu tout ça et je me dis
aujourd'hui on est quand même au 21ème
siècle est ce qu'on veut voir si la
mixité si du melting-pot et c'est ce qui
nous représente au sein de la france et
c'est ce qu'on veut voir demain donc
c'est un peu dans cette mobilité cette
ouverture maintenant on a besoin de ça
et ce qui est formidable quand je vous
écoute c'est que vous êtes à la fois
optimiste et positive et je pense que
c'est contagieux quand on est comme ça
non mais s'éveilla c'est bien mais il
faut que d'emblée c'est bien de votre
part que vous seriez comme ça parce que
j'ai battu complètement
c'est aussi pour ça que on est aussi là
présent parce qu'on a envie de partager
aussi bas ça c'est nrj on va dire
positive et puis on y croit aussi parce
que en accord les partenaires qu'on
rencontre au quotidien moi j'aime bien
effectivement communiquer partager
échanger hockey et finalement je fais le
bilan mais tout existe et en blesse leur
dis mais il manque ça mais non c'est à
côté de chez toi enfin
plus soit très confiant dans la nouvelle
génération
sur leur capacité à justement s'engager
le mot et affronter le monde de demain
bien sûr mais et de le faire avec une
nouvelle philosophie
une philosophie où ils font aussi très
soucieux sur leur leur bien-être
personnel le fait le développement
personnes qui s'est énormément
développée ces derniers temps les jeunes
en ont conscience ils veulent gagner de
l'argent c'est un des motifs numéro 1 a
dit qu'elle se faire plus tard je veux
gagner de l'argent mais pas au détriment
de valeurs de peut-être un engagement
très sadique le bol
[Rires]
des jeunes qui montrent un peu la voix
là dessus et qu'ils vont faire évoluer
des anciens dans le recrutement dans
l'air ça aussi ce qu'ils peuvent
apporter vos autres qui étaient pourtant
mois pour terminer bientôt on va passer
aux axiaux parce que c'est important les
actions qu'elle vous croyez celle que
vous voudriez mettre en oeuvre
la conclusion de cette démission
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que voilà vous avez
vous dit au fond c'est beau ce que vous
dites c'est tout est possible tout est
possible heureusement d'ailleurs
et heureusement c'est vrai que on
parlait de l'intergénération on parle du
numérique on parle de la mobilité donc
c'est vrai que ces sujets là sont très
présents au quotidien surpoids si on a
un bureau d'information jeunesse donc
c'est un bureau dans lequel on va
exactement sur la prévention sur les
études sur les jobs d'été sur voilà
presque on va vivre demain sur combien
va gagner quels sont les métiers et
c'est un bijou mobile aussi qu'ils se
déplacent dans les collèges dans les
lycées et je trouve que ces dispositifs
est très intéressant parce que celle
cesser ces référents qui l'a communiquée
au collège avec à tétine man des sujets
qui sont très présents sur
dumas naître et du décrochage scolaire
on a ce type de dispositif qui marche
très bien et j'aimerais encore plus le
fédérer au sein de la ville ait pu voir
avec les différents élus comment est-ce
qu'on peut fédérer encore plus ce
dispositif là on parlait de comités
aussi donc rassemblé un peu les acteurs
de la jeunesse autour d'une table parce
que chacun est son côté un petit peu
comme la co vide et finalement surtout
autour de la table pour échanger et ok
on parle de sujets mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait concrètement l'action de manière
pragmatique et comment est-ce qu'on
avance ensemble
moi j'ai envie de développer un
collectif de jeunes qui ce qui en fait
ce soient les ambassadeurs de la ville
c'est eux qui vont porter le message cv
ou qui ont qui vont être écoutés donc il
ya on a beaucoup de dispositifs comme
les l'académie roustan qui est aussi un
ne disposant la route inca démission
didier roustan grandjouan liste
régionaliste qui veulent bible en
matière de foot
sur la table
voilà quelque chose après 6
séances en se disant qu'ils n'ouvraient
formidable donc on a beaucoup de dix
places qu'en plus il dans sa démarche
cependant il ya là il ya le sport il ya
aussi des valeurs beaucoup d'autres ce
csc
c'est là où c'est intéressant parce
qu'on parle d'éducation et c'est un peu
aussi sur l'accompagnement des jeunes
sur l'apprentissage au niveau des
techniques mais aussi sur la pratique et
sur la projection voilà en quand on
l'est quand on les écoute on parle voilà
des différents footballeur parce qu'ils
ont fait mais finalement comment est-ce
qu'on se construit comment ce conte l on
parle on échange en termes d' équipe et
surtout sur la projection à chaque fois
on en passe fonds soient les valeurs
c'est ce qui fait la différence c'est ce
qui fait que les jeunes au final gillard
a appris ce serait construit dit
peut-être que demain je serai
journaliste peut-être que je serai comme
vous faites crise de cellules et
justement j'ai une question à vous poser
parce que il va y avoir les législatives
aux législatives sont là et il y à un
autre quand même une forte abstention
des jeunes
e
le terrain encore une fois le terrain
alors sur différents quartiers moi je
suis référente sur un quartier qui
s'appelle le quartier rouge de lille ce
sont des jeunes familles donc c'est vrai
que il ya des étiquettes en c'est sûr
c'est un travail des changes parce que
finalement aujourd'hui de droite de
gauche qui est important c'est les sujet
c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire demain
donc on parle effectivement la retraite
on parle des aînés on parle des écoles
aussi l'éducation et donc c'est des
sujets qui sont plus porteurs
aujourd'hui parce que voilà qu'on élise
et julie nous dans notre génération fait
beaucoup de métier on a beaucoup
d'expérience et qu'est ce qui nous
importe plus et qu'est ce qu'on va faire
demain donc au final c'est un peu plus
la sur les rails d'échangé de
communication donc c'est ce qu'on fait
au quotidien et on est en pleine
campagne donc
d'exemple c'est que le fait de s'engager
jeunes même si on n'a pas 18 ans mais de
s'engager jeunes cette saison
c'est une manière de montrer que l'on
peut et les autres c'est pas que pour
lui c'est notre responsabilité d'élus de
les prendre en considération est de
montrer que la vie d'élu c'est pas que
faire des réunions et puis décider de
loin des choses comme ça c'est aussi
être sur le terrain faire des beaux
événements qui s'adresse à eux donc ça
peut en effet donner envie donc je pense
que la place des cmj donc lé conseil
municipal jeunes ont un rôle hyper
important dans l'engagement il joue de
l'importance qu'on va leur donner accès
au si on décide dès le cm2 on les
apprend à peu a perdu une élection
il y avait pas avec ce
conseil c'est pas juste ce n'est pas
juste pour faire des photos
c'est important c'est de me dire voilà
deux d'eelv et à la des biberons et à la
démocratie si je veux dire je pense
qu'il devait sur ce sujet là c'est
important de vraiment sensibiliser les
jeunes mais régulièrement parce que les
jeunes crise on défend un souci avec
tout ce qui est
administration
c'est pour nos parents généralement
c'est à dire le vote assez pour les plus
grands alors qu' il faut pas laisser
décider quelqu'un d'autre de son avenir
et sur ça qu'il est important moi je
sais qu'à où il n'a pas voulu faire
parfois je ne leur parlez vous avez
l'occasion de vous parler aussi de nous
on peut leur en parler sur le terrain
qu'on al'occasion de de se croiser et
surtout là sur cette période où il ya eu
pas mal des deux élections qui vont se
suivre quand ces élections
présidentielles bon et généralement
ils disent y vont un peu plus après les
législatives pour que je comme les
français c'est ça que y'a pas que jade
qui s'abstiennent mais il ya une forte
abstention voilà c'est absolument sans
du compte de plus en plus de jeunes qui
sont
motivés par les sujets politiques et
donc je pense aussi c'est vrai que c'est
important de montrer l'exemple en étant
grill et gj ça lorsque vous faites ça
peut être ça peut être des exemples
c'est que à poissy un conseil municipal
junior et c'est vrai que et mois avant
d'être élu je trouvais ce dispositif
génial parce que ce sont des petits qui
vont représenter la république donc les
valeurs l'espèce et au final en fait
c'est très tôt vous faites les sujets
que l'on rencontre et du pouvoir suivre
en fait le cmj c'est important pour les
petits comme les peaux à dos et c'est
les premiers à être un peu les curseurs
de la vie et je trouve que les valeurs
dont la réplique aujourd'hui qu'on a un
petit peu perdues effectivement comme le
disait si l'air c'est un monde aux
adultes non non c'est de maintenant on a
besoin de vous pour avancer on a besoin
de vous pour échanger échoue que la
réplique aujourd'hui n'a besoin d'être
de la retrouver de d'instaurer des
nouvelles valeurs et un nouveau sens je
pense que si on est une génération
interne a envie de faire bouger les
lignes donc la république aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'elle dit et qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait alors part à une prochaine
fois je n'ai pas du metavers
et du monde de demain auquel vous
intéressait aussi merci infiniment merci
merci merci julie zones a et b on se bat
ça serait pas mal de faire le point
comme ça de temps en temps
[Musique]
merci merci en tout cas merci m très
vite bas pour un nouveau numéro de vol
je crois que la prochaine fois on
parlera probablement des législatives
[Musique]